your boys ready to try this I mean I'm
not ready look it says it here on the
internet where every true thing is guys
are making videos of themselves dipping
their balls in soy sauce claiming they
can taste the salt we're gonna
experiment see if you can tell the
difference between water and I want to
get my dick in that soy sauce just your
balls I gotta work out our balls gonna
be black who's looking at your balls in
it that would be an impression on you
the question is will you shower when you
go home whatever's on all five times
there is a new internet trend where men
are dipping their balls and soy sauce so
in front of us we have soy sauce so
how's this gonna work arey um so what's
gonna happen Sal go first I was gonna
put his blindfold put on your blindfold
blindfold and then I'm just gonna pick I
wouldn't have to do both and he's gonna
have to tell me which one was which all
right give it a shot you ready Sal I'm
ready all right I'm gonna kill this
music Freddie just because I really
don't want to miss a thing
okay can you lift your dick up no you
dick up yes you don't dig perfect you
ready yeah oh it's cold all right
is it soy sauce Wow you won't believe
this I immediately I immediately got the
taste of soy sauce are you serious I
swear to God it went through my nostrils
and all my taste buds Gary is that in
fact soy sauce no it's water let's see
if I can taste it even more the water
was amazing good good water your ball
right now this this is why are you
sniffing think it's so strong in the
nose you taste anything no how would I
could taste absolutely not let's try it
on Richard and by the way Oh such a
strong smell in here Richard did you
bathe recently Sunday I do and what is
today Tuesday yeah you got an odor yeah
I caught a whiff it's
it's what salars or it's him he told me
didn't shower why Richard why not shower
yes no time at all I'm so busy yeah what
you're grabbing a two-year-old son Gary
gently form to put the blindfold on Gary
just grab the cup and show it to Richard
I didn't see it luckily all right now
yeah put your put your blindfold on Gary
what's with you fooling them don't worry
you're pulling I don't think you know
what you doing I think Richard or maybe
I'll hold Richard's nose because the
smell gives it away Howard so does all
right hold it take a shower and keep
Gary Gary lift my dick up
oh yeah Gary's gonna have to lift it
lift up you dick oh okay it's cold his
balls are in the solution I I don't
taste anything
I mean I'm gonna that's huh oh now get a
little salt right give it give it give
it a second let's see what happens leave
your balls and they in the solution huh
yeah I'm getting a little salty taste
sensation I think that's the soy sauce
Gary it is the soy sauce one Richard has
taste buds in his bowl you know what it
is and what I think would that happen
with Sal you got to leave it in there
for a minute do you really feel you
could taste some salty since oh yeah I
felt a weird like not really a taste but
like something soaking in my balls that
tingled it a little get out of here now
go wash your balls off in the sink good
job boys the soy sauce covers up my
stink idli yeah that did help I got it
you